il
oh
compétente courageuse déjà
c'est l'excellence dans sa matière trois
joueuses
bonjour au bien et au mal c'est qu'on me
la mets là nous les à la ferme et 15 du
grand étang dans les hauts de saint
benoît au programme aujourd'hui où est
grosse journée donc ce matin plein nez
cassé cet après-midi berry avec de
jeunes chevaux c'est la malade grandit
donc que m'a toujours vécu finalement un
grand étang pour payet et puis ben
monter à cheval grâce découvrir les
chevaux grâce à papa m'a mis la doyenne
32 ans
oui j'ai menti j'ai eu la chance de
pouvoir grandir avec les chevaux en
effet de pouvoir partir ailleurs et de
vivre de belles choses ailleurs et mal a
eu la chance du coup il a besoin de très
belles rencontres que la dernière main
d'évoluer de progresser de mieux
comprendre nos temps l'animal et mais
aussi d'une certainement mieux
comprendre la main c'est aussi d'être
parfait et c'est vrai que l appui
elle a fait un choix d'être prophète
déjà de par ce qu'elle fait parce que le
cheval ça pardonne pas ce qu'elle fait
mais mes enfants est elle aussi en
particulier n'ont pas eu à la butte
jeunesse la vie d'adolescent qu'ils
auraient pu prétendre simplement parce
que ricco avait la tête dans le guidon
et
là
je vais y voient ils voient acteurs à
mon retour à la réunion mme avait envie
mais même a été peut-être déçus
d'ailleurs au début ne pas pouvoir faire
que tout le monde a envie de faire
l'équitation éthologique n'est pas fait
pour tout le monde qui cherchent à
partir je peux retenir bouger les
hanches tourner sur moi-même et du coup
là au moins ceci tient ce petit pont
c'est bien à la filière cheval ça a été
assez assez sévères donc c'est un milieu
qui est assez fermé
on essaie de faire nous les jeunes c'est
nourrir un peu les portes s'ouvrir un
peu les méthodes d'apprentissage d'être
un petit peu moins sévère de comprendre
le comportement du cheval n'est pas
sanctionné a tout le temps el watan
c'est sur la partie compréhension est ce
la partie fondation posé de bonnes
fondations sur l'éducation de nos
chevaux et apprendre des solutions à des
problèmes courants de soins de maréchal
fin des défauts dit difficile mais
toujours guillemets parce qu'il n'a pas
le chemin difficile mais une relation en
difficulté et au fur et à mesure quand
il arrêtera de te dépasser ses biens du
coup tu vas commencer pouvant utiliser
ton reculé pour enfants c'est aussi ton
art y tient oui quand tu es prête arrête
toi et tu vas n'hésite pas donc tout ce
que tu ne veux pas en inconfortable
tout ce qui te convient donc rend le
confortable surtout qu'on se comprend et
ça c'est important de que lui
comprennent ce que je moi le moi je lui
demande et que que moi je comprenne ce
que ce que lui
ce que lui recherche ce qu'il attend de
moi c'est important c'est philosophique
société il faudrait il faudrait ça
ferait pas de mal
on est à bérive
le programme mais sous la pluie si la
pluie permet surtout c'est anémone et
whitney dans un autre soldat oui
anémone
je vous qui a besoin qui a besoin
d'éducation et c'est surtout le maître
aussi déjà passé nous nous si on fait
des erreurs les chevaux ils vont le
ressentir c'est comme dans les chiens
quand je compte je faisais ça et
ultérieurement
c'est vrai que les chevaux ils vont
recevoir notre notre angoisse ou si nous
aide pas le cheval à mieux comprendre le
monde domestique dans lequel ils censés
évoluer
nous ne peut partir vite à la
catastrophe
le bape prendre refuge dans les bras
ça c'est pas possible non va falloir
qu'elle y apprendre à vivre cet état
émotionnel non pas dans la film et non
pas dans mes bras non plus mes peurs ben
m'hidi pas mal a jamais eu peur après du
coup apprend à maîtriser
j'ai fait de la réussite qu'elle
intervienne dans tous les clubs et
qu'elle arrive à changer à la réunion
les mentalités autour du cheval qui va
pas être évident tu passes ton temps de
jeu je t'aime et on connait que en scène
et je connais ce que finalement cette
responsabilité et devons l'assumer
environ 1 aguicheuse williams la date
nous y sommes pas là où s'harmonisent
pour ça aussi quelque chose de magique
qu'on a des chances de revanche